I still think that great story that you
did on The Tonight Show with when Nicole
Kidman was a guest she said she was
interested in you sexually yeah she
comes over to your apartment and Nicole
Kim's hot and famous and you know before
you were married it was the worst how
did you not pick up on this cuz I was on
S live and I was just I was just single
and just walking around and just just
being whatever I just being in the
bachelor life and then you sat there and
played video games while she sat there
and like was trying to seduce you well
here's what happened my friend Rick
calls me he goes dude Nicole K I'm with
Nicole kib and she wants to come to your
apartment she was to meet with you about
I thought about a project uh um it was
Nor Efron redid it the Bewitched oh so I
go wow cool it ended up going to Will
Farrell but I was like cool I could play
they were thinking of you being being
Darren Darren yeah I could see that
that'd be fun yeah I go great I go
fantastic he goes so I go but my place
is a mess I don't know what's going on
Nicole kimman you can't bring let's meet
somewhere else he goes no we just go to
the she wants to go to the apartment I
go all right he goes just get some
cheese and crackers and and it'll be I
go cheese and crackers I going to get
that what cheese he goes just get Brie
and crackers and I go okay so I don't
even know what brie is right so I go
into the deli by my house I go you have
any Brie like what and I was like I
don't even know what it is so I grab Bri
which I don't know what it is and I grab
I bought
Saltines and saltin it's so embarrassing
and I seriously I put it on a plate and
I opened the plastic wrap of the
saltines and I kind of fanned it out a
little bit to make it look fancy yeah oh
you made a presentation exactly thank
you man your bachelor pad and I don't
have a cheese knife so I have a butter
knife yeah and the thing of Bri which I
go do I take this thing off the plastic
the Rind yeah I didn't even know it's
called the Ry at the time I go I don't
know what I do with this I scoop out the
middle this is the whole thing's a
nightmare see I would have opened a can
of nuts then you have no there no quam
about the peanut allergy oh yeah maybe
all right you can't win anymore so she
walks in she walks in I go wow and I'm
like nervous did you think she was hot
she's gorgeous gorgeous right gorgeous I
mean it's a no-brainer by far the most
beautiful person ever walked in my
apartment but you thought it was like oh
if she's discussing the movie I'm trying
to be professional right yeah I mean I
want to be someone you want to work in a
movie with three months yeah not some
guy who's just going to jump on top of
me yeah right plus I wouldn't even
consider that I would have a chance in
my life with Kim so she sits down and
she goes no what what are all these
wires or some of that what are these
wires yeah I can't do Australian but me
and I go uh this that's a Nintendo game
I have Nintendo game she goes what what
kind what games you playing and I was
like uh now she's British she she like
Rick Ricky D actually David Bowie
no I'm about to have an affair with
David Bowie so I go uh Mario Kart
anyways I teach her I go you want to see
how to play you practice the gas I don't
even know what I was doing and I taught
her how to play the video game Mario
Kart oh so and you didn't get the part I
didn't get the part and then she I never
heard this story until The Tonight Show
she came on the show and she goes you
know I have a story I want do you
remember meeting me and I hate those
things I don't remember meeting anyone I
think I mean I think I remember meeting
most people I relate I don't remember
Karly Simon telling me stuff I know so I
go uh gosh I don't even know what the
story is and then she told the story
live on The Tonight Show except she said
she was interested in you sexually yeah
yeah and you're like wow I was just
playing video
games